down but not completely out some of
these rough sleepers have jobs
builders bar staff couriers
this is the cardboard economy it's 6 45
am and after a rough night in the
streets florian packs up his box
mattress
hides his sleeping bag and goes to
charing cross station
to make himself respectable the
lockdown came and then everything got
cancelled and from there
i ended homeless because i wasn't
getting enough money
i have run out of money i messed up the
lands
and i to be very honest i started a bit
of drinking
which i'm not really a drinker but
because i was staying home a lot
depression started and everything and i
lost the place and
i came to london for a fresh start and
this fresh start even with the work now
i still can't get ahead it's no way for
me of getting ahead
he's one of around 75 000 homeless or
nearly homeless people
who manage to hold down a job his
employers
and fellow workers have no idea of his
circumstances
but by 8am he's a hard day's work ahead
renovating
some of london's most expensive
properties
what's it like you know sleeping here
and then going to job in the morning i
wouldn't wish anybody to do
what i would have been doing till now i
don't wish that to anybody
darting through london's financial
sector is another homeless man
courier nick rose says it's the gig
economy
that's made him homeless 2018
uh they'd way over hired a
they call it onboarding they over
onboarded for christmas made sure that
they had enough workers
came to january and then all of a sudden
we had
the loads of workers and not enough
ships yeah it was saturated
oversaturated and a lot of times we're
not even dealing with humans
we are just dealing with an app and
mostly it's just an algorithm on an app
which is even
divvying out the work and deciding who
gets to do what
um so your life is controlled by an
algorithm
yeah yeah unfortunately yeah so it's
very faceless
i bought a tent from decathlon um ten
pounds from decathlon and a ten pound
sleeping bag from decathlon
and uh moved into the nearest churchyard
it's a really unfriendly and threatening
looking world you know it's very bleak
and
keeping your spirits up is next to
impossible nick is now at least in
hostile
but homeless charities such as this food
bank in central london
say the homeless demographic is changing
i don't think it's the archetypal
homeless person we once knew
it's people finding ourselves on hard
times that may not used to being
in that position we're talking about
hard work and ordinary people these days
that are
falling off the ladder and finding
nowhere to live another form of
homelessness
is temporary accommodation fatima lives
in a single room
with her 10 year old son this is
basically a room
with a bathroom and this is the kitchen
area
and this is my bedroom this is a double
room so this is everything
yeah this is all the living space you
have yeah we're looking at it
yep unfortunately but yeah
um how does that feel
it's not good because there's not enough
space for me and my son
she works at the ymca but it's low
income and she's been trapped here for
five years
when it should have been a matter of
weeks even so we soon discover
she's not even allowed to have guests
[Music]
she's not allowed to have visitors she's
not have any visitors
you're kidding me
why has she not allowed her visitors
they're treating us like kids and all
the cameras it's like prison but prison
get visitors
yeah here we're not allowed
these are people clinging to an
existence after a day's work
florian prepares for another night
sleeping rough
homeless charities fear post-pandemic
many more people could be joining this
grim
sub-sector of our economy jason farrell
sky news